acusaban a las autoridades rusas de no
actuar pero este viernes un tribunal
rechazó una denuncia presentada por los
aliados del crítico del kremlin alexéi
navalni en esta acusaban a un alto
organismo de aplicación de la ley de
inacción sobre lo que dijeron que era un
intento de asesinato
que aprobó ninguna decisión sobre la
apertura de un caso criminal u otra
decisión tomada por el comité de
investigación de acuerdo con el código
del procedimiento penal
un día antes la unión europea instó al
gobierno ruso a llevar a cabo una
investigación exhaustiva y transparente
del caso nabhani y por primera vez se
refirió a posibles sanciones
el uso de armas químicas en cualquier
circunstancia es completamente
inaceptable y una violación del derecho
internacional
la unión europea fue muy clara en su
firme condena del uso de este agente
químico contra el señor naval
mista naval en respuesta el kremlin
rechazó cualquier sugerencia de que
rusia hubiera estado detrás del ataque y
dijo que no veía motivos para imponer
sanciones amos
sí no
no creo que pueda ser beneficioso para
alguien si se piensa alguien no queremos
que nuestros socios en alemania y en
otros países europeos se precipiten en
estimaciones preferiríamos estar en
diálogo
estas declaraciones llegaron un día
después de que la cancillera alemana
angela merkel dijera que el oponente
ruso había sido envenenado por un agente
de tipo no bitch coc este caso también
podría tener graves consecuencias para
el proyecto de gasoducto nord stream 2
que se esperaba suministrará gas ruso a
europa ya alemania en particular